AND LAWYER GEORGE CONWAY.
GEORGE, YOU SAID IT WAS
DISGRACEFUL AND APPALLING FOR
SENATOR GRAHAM AND OTHER
REPUBLICANS TO ATTACK LAW
ENFORCEMENT VERBALLY AFTER THIS
SEARCH AT MAR-A-LAGO OR TO
SUGGEST THAT THE FBI PLANTED
EVIDENCE.
ARE YOU CONCERNED THAT THOSE
SORTS OF COMMENTS ARE INSPIRING
ATTACKS ON THE FBI, LIKE THE ONE
WE JUST SAW IN OHIO TODAY?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THEY'RE PAYMENTING A PICTURE TO
SOME VERY UNFORMED AND SOME VERY
SICK PEOPLE OUT THERE, LIKE THIS
GENTLEMAN KILLED IN OHIO, THAT
THE GOVERNMENT IS TYRANNICAL AND
VICTIMIZING DONALD TRUMP.
AND THERE ARE THESE DIES AND
FRANKLY NOT JUST THE SPREADING
OF THEM, BUT THE INABILITY OF
REPUBLICAN LEADERSHIP TO DENY
THESE LIES.
THEY SIMPLY GO ALONG WITH THEM,
THIS IS DANGEROUS BECAUSE IT'S
ENCOURAGING PEOPLE TO BASICALLY
DEFY THE RULE OF LAW.
WHAT DONALD TRUMP DID ON JANUARY
6th TO STAY IN OFFICE, HE'LL
CERTAINLY TRY TO DO TO STAY OUT
OF JAIL, WHICH IS TO FOMENT
VIOLENCE ON HIS BEHALF.
>> GEORGE, I WANT TO TALK TO YOU
ABOUT THE STATEMENT WE GOT FROM
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
HE WAS VERY BLUNT AFTER BREAKING
HIS SILENCE.
HE SPOKE FOR A COUPLE OF
MINUTES.
SAID HE SIGNED OFF ON THIS
PERSONALLY, ASKED FOR THE SEARCH
WARRANT TO BE UNSEALED, DOING IT
FORMALLY.
AND TRUMP, WHO SAID HE WANTS
EVERYTHING OUT THERE, IS NOW
MAYBE GOING TO MOVE TO BLOCK
THAT.
SO THERE'S THAT GOING ON.
HOW MUCH DO YOU THINK WE COULD
LEARN FROM IT IF WE DO SEE THE
WARRANT?
>> I THINK WE'RE GOING TO LEARN
THAT THINGS WERE DONE BY THE
BOOK.
I DON'T THINK WE'RE GOING TO
LEARN THE FULL STORY BEHIND THIS
INVESTIGATION, BY WILL BE LAID
OUT IN THE PROBABLE CAUSE
AFFIDAVIT, WHICH WILL REMAIN
UNDER SEAL, BUT WE'LL SEE WHAT
IT IS.
THE FBI AND THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT WERE LOOKING FOR AT
MAR-A-LAGO, AND WE WILL SEE WHAT
THEY CAME OUT WITH.
THERE IS GOING TO BE A TICKET OR
LIST OF ITEMS THAT THE
GOVERNMENT IS REQUIRED TO
PRODUCE, OTHER THINGS, THE
PROPERTY THAT THEY TOOK.
AND SO WE'RE GOING TO SEE WHAT
IT IS THAT'S AT STAKE HERE, NOT
NECESSARILY SPECIFICALLY THE
DOCUMENTS.
SOME OF THEM MAY, APPARENTLY
ACCORDING TO SOME REPORTING, IS
TOP SECRET.
BUT WE'LL LEARN THAT THERE WAS A
THERE THERE.
>> AND IN YOUR OPINION, GEORGE,
IS THAT ENOUGH?
YOU SAID THERE'S NO WAY WE WOULD
HAVE GOTTEN TO THIS POINT IF
THESE WERE JUST TOP SECRET
DOCUMENTS, THAT THIS WOULD HAVE
GONE DOWN DIFFERENTLY.
DO YOU SHARE THAT CONCERN, OR DO
YOU THINK IT REALLY IS, BY THE
LETTER OF THE LAW, BY THE BOOK,
FOR TOP SECRET DOCUMENTS, THAT
IS STILL THE RIGHT THING OF
DONE?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
TAKE A STEP BACK.
SAY YOU HAD A -- I'M GOING
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISER OR AN
OUTGOING ASSISTANT TO THE
PRESIDENT WHO TOOK THESE VERY
BOXES OF MATERIALS HOME WITH
THEM ON JANUARY 20th, 2021.
I MEAN, THERE WOULD BE NO
QUESTION THAT IF THEY JERKED
AROUND THE GOVERNMENT, AND
REFUSED TO TURN THE MATERIALS
BACK OVER, EVEN AFTER BEING
SUBPOENAED, WHICH APPARENTLY WAS
THE CASE HERE, I CAN'T IMAGINE
THERE COULDN'T BE CHARGES
BROUGHT.
>> THAT'S MORE LIKE SANDY
BERGER.
>> YEAH, HE TOOK ONE PIECE OF
PAPER AND STUFFED IT IN HIS
SOCK.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT MAYBE TWO
DOZEN BOXES, WHO KNOWS, OF
MATERIALS, OF THE HIGHEST
SENSITIVITY.
THESE ARE THINGS THAT THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
RECEIVED.
OKAY, THIS IS ABOUT THE MOST
SENSITIVE OF SENSITIVE
INFORMATION THAT YOU CAN
IMAGINE.
AND HE VIEWED THEM BECAUSE HE IS
THE WORLD'S ULTIMATE NARCISSIST,
AS HIS PROPERTY.
AND HE THOUGHT HE COULD TAKE
THEM AND THEYBELONGED TO HIM,
JUST LIKE HIS GENERALS AT THE
PENTAGON BELONGED TO HIM.
IT ALL BELONGS TO HIM AND SOME
LOSER NERD LIBRARIAN WANTS TO
TAKE THAT AWAY FROM HIM.
YOU CAN SEE HOW THIS HAPPENED.
AND, YOU KNOW, THIS COULD BE